howdy-ho how's it going so today we are
going to try out the DET är the end to
end object detection with transformers
from facebook AI research and they have
a github repo and they pretty much give
you everything like the model the pre
trained weights and so on so today we're
going to check out how easy it is to get
started with that so in order to do that
they have like a collab but we we won't
look at it too much
I've glanced at it and we'll basically
see how far can we go without looking at
it too much and how easy is that so what
I've done is I've spun up a collab that
I will share at the end and I've
imported torch and just loaded the model
so you don't have to wait for that to
happen so I've loaded that up and now we
have it in the cache so now we can
basically go ahead and load an image
into the model and try to detect objects
in the image so first of all this is
super easy right you simply load this
from torch hub it's kind of like the the
tensorflow hub you simply give the name
of the model you say I want the pre
trained please chugga-boom you now have
a model so if we look at that model this
is going to be this entire Det our model
right here with all the transformer and
ResNet and whatnot okay this is almost a
bit too much right here so what we want
is an image so let's go find an image
where better they find an image than
Google so let's find an image of dogs
because dogs is one of the classes in
this cocoa dataset this one's nice right
okay so we want the image address we
want to load it in here somehow so so
that the URL is let's make this into
some sort of like an input thing where
we can paste the URL right here okay
there we go so we have this right here
and that's the URL all right no that's
not the URL at all
is it but a beam but a boom
what about cool better now we need to
load this for that we gonna use the
requests library always a pleasure
requests requests so the way to load a
binary file is you can put the URL here
and you can say streamed here I glanced
this from the other thing and the raw
entry will get you the eventual deeply
bytes no oh sorry
get darrell streamed stream yeah so this
will get you the sort of the the bytes
of the image and then use just say image
dot open and of course we need the image
from a the pill library the python image
library so import image we got that and
we can open that image up and with a bit
of luck yeah yeah so this model expects
I think cocoa dataset is 640 by 480
images but they if you can see right
here and we're gonna take a quick glance
at their transforming they resize it to
800 so we're gonna we're gonna steal
that part right here people last time
where some some found it really funny
that I called copy pasting to go Suraj
so will from now and we'll call it just
Suraj Inge what we also need are the
class labels because that's in defined
in the cocoa dataset right so these are
the class labels let's take those and
okay so this T here these are torch
vision transforms we're gonna need that
so from say
so if you don't know torch vision it's
kind of an addition to PI torch that
just helps you with with images and has
a lot of data sets and these transforms
they're really helpful because so let's
call this image because you can you know
resize but they have much more like
random cropping and rotating images and
so on pretty much everything you need
for pre-training and this here is just
the standard image net I believe the
image net normalization so these are the
means and these are the standard
deviations from the image net data set
and let's already resize our image
actually to this weight hundred and I
believe I believe if you rescale the 640
to 800 you get 600 here right fairly
sure okay and then let's display it just
because we can okay what it's it's a bit
squished but we don't care and let's put
that up here so we only need to execute
it once nice okay so from now on it
should be a breeze so what these
transforms do is they resize the image
okay we don't need that anymore they
make it into a tensor and then they
normalize by that so if we run our image
through this because our image right now
is this is pill image right so our our
image is this pill image but if we run
it through the transforms then we'll get
a tensor so that's pretty cool so the
model as it is a deep learning model
that expects batches so we'll unscrew is
that in the first dimension and then we
get batches so shape let's see we don't
have on skis no of course we don't so
this is a one image of three channels of
600 by 800 so this is the Y index
coordinates I guess are shifted
yes in pi torch cool so we'll call this
our image tensor now we just need to put
it into the model so model we put that
in there and since we don't let's
actually up here put the model in eval
mode I don't know if that's already done
but you know you can never be sure
enough that the batch norms aren't so I
think it probably doesn't have batch
norms okay you're not utilizing the GPU
we'll do that we'll do that
Thanks so how do we use the GPU we put
our model on the GPU model equals model
CUDA yes yes yes I think so
this is gonna work okay we're gonna come
back to this later
so we forward our image of course we
also need that on the GPU and it's
worked did this work this worked nice
okay and since this is just for
evaluation we should probably go with no
grad right here because we don't need
this whole gradient stuff if we do that
okay I'm dumb
there you go and nothing happens of
course because we need to capture the
output somehow let's look at that output
Wow Wow just wow so the output is a
dictionary right because we get back
class labels and bounding boxes so let's
look at the bread boxes let's look at
that tensor that's a tensor very nice
let's look at its shape let's not print
giant tensors anymore
cool so since this was a batch of one we
should probably go
the zeroeth and you can see right here
there is a hundred bounding boxes and
each one has four numbers and if you go
with the other thing that's in there the
log it's then you'll see that there are
also should be a hundred log it's and
hello there should be a hundred log it's
and each one is of size 92 because there
are 92 different classes 92 we'll see
about that
well one is going to be the nothing
class right by the way how many classes
do we have we have 91 classes okay cool
we can deal with that all right so what
are we gonna do next what we want to do
is for each of the for each of the for
each of the log it predictions we want
to find which classic corresponds to so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take the Arg max of the last dimension
right so you can see here almost all of
these things correspond to class 91 and
class 91 is not in our classes because
our class is only length 91 so that must
be the nothing class so what we can
technically do is for log its and boxes
in let's just zip them together and
[Music]
like this okay class is oops
class as the law gets Arg max if that's
92 or let's say safe that's larger than
the length of our classes we'll just
skip it for now okay so that should work
somehow and if not then our label should
be the class index right here so let's
just see what the detector detects right
here it detects nothing why does it
detect nothing that's isn't seem good
what are we doing wrong we zip together
the log it's oh yeah of course we still
need the zero with entry we are dumb
dumb dumb
cool so so so so we can delete this and
now finally beautiful dogs - dogs
detected excellent so now for each of
these dogs we want the bounding box okay
so now we somehow need to think of how
are we gonna draw this on an image and
well let's let's actually make a copy of
that image because I don't really trust
myself and then at the end of this we're
just going to display that image right
now actually the reason I make a copy is
because in these in this pillow library
you can actually draw on these images
and we're going to
that to draw these bounding boxes so for
that we need an image draw if I remember
correctly and I think later we also want
some text so we need an image font yes
all right so let's draw a bounding box
right here where so first of all let's
look at that bounding box let's call
this box box print box dot shape and
break right here what's happening let's
not do this right now so this is a boxes
of size four now this could be two
things it could be X 0 y 0 X 1 Y 1 so
the two corner points or the kind of the
boundaries or it could be X Y width
height now from the paper I know that
they predict the center and the width
and the height so I'm gonna go with that
and I'm just gonna guess that it's like
X Y WH and not some other way around
if this is a bad guess then yeah we'll
see we can just print out one of these
boxes and honestly that looks reason oh
by the way we should scale that up yeah
so these are normalized coordinates
probably between 0 and 1 so we should
scale that up so we should probably the
x coordinates which is scaled by 800 and
the Y by 600 so let's do it so first of
all we scale our box by 800 in the X and
here is a Y and the width is the X
direction and this is the Y Direction
boom
okay we should probably get that on CPU
will just hack together a bunch of
things right here ok so now this isn't
the correct so we sold our x and y and
WH are going to be this box so now we
need to actually draw on the image we're
gonna do that so let's first go X 0 X 1
is X minus W 1/2 X plus W half y 0 y 1
is the same for a y with H plus H half
Coolio
now we need an image draw object so I
think draw on this image so whatever you
draw on the draw object will end up on
the image so we can use that to draw a
bounding box and let's just quickly look
it up so pill Python draw rectangle
maybe there we go okay so there's this
rectangle yeah there's the rectangle
function and you can see you put in a
shape XY here and width height like this
wait for real we wouldn't even have to
need to transform it I'm pretty sure you
can go X I thought I remember you could
do the different thing as well but it's
called rectangle okay so let's do that
so draw rectangle and we'll go we'll go
X 0 or we'll go X Y width height let's
display that down here yeah that looks
that looks nothing like we want but it's
you know it's a start maybe actually we
need the other thing here we need X 0 y
0 X 1 Y 1 mm yes yes doggy okay we still
have the break in here
now we get both dogs nice nice
okay let's do I think Phil yes red and
let's go for with five or so five seems
like a good width
oh god five is a terrible with oh it's
not feel I think it's its outline yeah
yeah okay okay let's go still go with
five cool we got our dogs now we need to
put like some some snappy text labels I
think there's actually a pill image draw
text I think that exists because I've
this font thing yeah exactly so you need
the font thing get it font in there
and then yeah exactly you could put a
text like this okay
so you probably need the x and y
coordinates of the text so let's do that
W dot text and let's just go with x and
y right here put it right in the middle
and the text is going to be our label of
course and we want the fill that's now
going to be the color of the text let's
go with white and the font we're going
to load some font right here font dot
how we're doing this
true type true type ah no not cheating
let's just go with regular fonts it
won't look as fancy but we'll be fine
so we're where is our text
you see it I don't see it red
let's make it red yes there we go okay
so it wasn't red enough this should work
on it so I did we just I just not see it
I'm domina
cool so we have two dogs how easy was
that actually we wasted the most time
with like bounding boxes and stuff
absolutely cool right okay so now we can
have some fun with it I'm going to scale
this down for a bit because you don't
need to see the actual code anymore so
much so you can see the image more so
we'll go to the images and the first
thing I want to do is the dress what
does this think of the dress okay so
we'll copy that and we'll go into our
collab and just paste this right here
butter boom but a beam sounds nice and
what is wrong the size of a tensor must
match the size of a tensor we do
something wrong
transform image or images this
maybe this is like an RGBA image I think
if this is rgba we should just convert
it to like an RGB pretty sure you can do
something like this right here this
should work as an alpha Channel then
that will remove it yes now it works
okay let's see what the model thinks of
this yeah okay
apparently there's a car and there's a
surfboard and there's a person and
there's a person nice see well we didn't
figure out whether the dress was blue or
white through gold it was just a person
now they you could actually like
threshold by how sure you are of a given
class but where's the fun in that
so let's go further and let's do some
Rorschach inkblots because those are
always lots and lots of fun so which one
should we go for it this one looks like
fun okay so we'll put this into here and
it's astonishing right it's this cocoa
data said it only has these 90 classes
like it doesn't have anything anything
else so it's a cake it's a cake and this
here what is it okay we'll have to go
maybe with blue what is it stop sign
okay but so you might think it what if
what if we want more like what if we
want more predictions so there is a hack
right right now the model can always
assign math to this not a class thing
like right here this class 91 in order
for it to say I don't think there's
anything there but
generally we have a hundred predictions
right so you see where this is going so
yes let's let's change it but let's
change it up a bit and let's go here
let's first extract these tensors and
boxes okay so we have the boxes and this
and log its and boxes okay so we got
that what we wanna do is basically we
want to filter the we want to basically
just remove the last class before we do
the Arg max and thereby we want to force
the model to make a prediction now it
won't be a very good prediction because
of course this is only the second
highest class and it's arguable how much
that counts but still it will do
something so this must be done in the
log it's right so well look at the log
it's and the log it's our of shape 100
so we have 100 predictions of 92 classes
now the first thing we want to do is
just remove the last class so let's go
everything here until the last class all
right so now we have 91 actually let's
make it more generic whatever thing
however many classes are okay so we
don't have this class anymore so now if
we do the softmax over the last thing we
can technically we get 91 but now
they're normalized so they add up to one
so it's kind of a probability
distribution next we we want to find the
max over this and that that will give us
a max output so we don't want to plot
all the 100 predictions because that
would just be like like squares all over
the place and we'd have no clue what
happening so this max output right here
this what we're trying to find is we're
trying to find a let's say the five best
predictions or so the five ones where
the model thinks where the model is most
confident it's not really good metric
but you know so these are the
probability values of all of the hundred
predictions so what we want is like the
top K okay so let's go with five and
again we'll get like a top K output
let's call that top K and I think it
also has like values and indices yes so
now we simply need to filter from the
log it's and the boxes where these these
top ones are so well filter the log it's
[Music]
will filter the log it's by that top K
indices and we'll also filter thee I am
not very gifted today boxes
by the way I'm using a collab just
because it's nice to kind of play around
with a model because if I were to use a
file I'd have to restart reload the
model over and over again just not as
nice so now we have the log it's and the
boxes and if we do that right now we get
always the top 5 predictions how nice is
that and you can see the top 5
predictions are probably still kkkkkk
cake
and just to verify that and we can put
its shape yeah see this is what I don't
like about this stuff yes okay so we
just have five predictions of 92 things
and we don't want the 92 we've already
said so we just want the 91 let's
actually could put that here
[Music]
okay so now we have five by 91 and now
to give us the top five are there we go
so many takes and many stop sighs that's
fine that's cool
so the ultimate test right here is going
to be yes the human adversarial example
let's check it out
so we put in a Jackson Pollock image and
we'll see what the model says now we're
actually forcing it to make predictions
right so it can't escape it will need to
do something okay I made another mistake
I would need to copy the image address
right here like this
that's what happens when you're not an
idiot you get the actual image so what
does the model think of our pretty image
okay can't even read that so let's make
this into white bird bird bird okay lots
of birds in this image clearly clearly
lots of birds in this image let's try
another one let's go with this this this
one yes yes absolutely
love it love it okay so we copy image
address and beam
Mormons Wow there's a lot of birds in
these Pollock images just so many birds
okay let's try one last how about this
one this one is a bit more
human-friendly right put it in here and
and and okay we get some detections
there's a clock right here there is a
what's that
how's horses let's print let's print the
labels so just so we know what they are
cake horse car horse and clock okay so I
see the clock like this here is clearly
a clock then this rectangle on the right
side must be something let's put this to
read as well
now that's terrible ah white back to
white how about back to white okay clock
we got horse right here and house
probably and the entire image is again a
cake yes okay
so as you can see it is a pretty pretty
good system but of course it is only
these 90 classes but it's for now it's a
it's pretty cool and it works pretty
well and just the easiness with which
you get which which you can get this
stuff elephants in
Kruger National Park just the easiness
is astonishing you can just load it up
kind of have this have a bit of a
notebook and with a bit of like a very
few lines of code you can put something
together that detects these bounding
boxes lots of elephants and remember we
only have the top five elephants right
here so what happens if we go for more
where is our top k so here we can let
maybe say the top 15 predictions and as
always if we want to make the model to
make its own decision we can simply
revert back and add back the no class
label all right with that I hope you
like this video if you did then maybe
tell YouTube that you liked it share it
out and I will share this notebook in
the description for you to find and play
around with alright thanks for watching
bye bye